こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
なんかTwitterかなTwitter
で見たんですけど僕住んでるこの家はじめ
しゃちょーの3億円のお家かなり大きいし
見た目にインパクトありますよ
なんか俺のこの家をゲームでゲームで再現
したやつがいるらしいんですよ
再現できるの本当にこの家結構複雑よいや
分かんない外装だけかもしれません見た目
だけかもしれない中までがちょっとまだ俺
見てないからわかんないけどなんかゲーム
でこの家を完全再現した方がいらっしゃる
みたいな話を聞いたのでちょっとその
ゲーム今回
遊んでいきたいと思いますこの家をゲーム
で再現されるの多分初ですなてか再現
できるちょっとかなり疑問が残ってるん
ですけども早速ゲームで遊んでいきたいと
思いますでなんか再現したゲームがあの超
人気
有名ゲームフォートナイトらしいです
すなわちですよこれ簡単に言うとフォート
ナイトではじめ社長の佐野系の家が実装さ
れたってことなんですよ
何しと何日とどうやってフォートナイトで
そういうシステムあったんだっけちょっと
わからなすぎるので早速ゲームの方
ちょっと遊んでいきたいと思います
マジか
はいというわけで早速やっていこうと思い
ますフォートナイトねいや何回か遊んだ
ことあるんですけども全然上手くないし
超絶プレーとかもわかんない素人なんです
けどもこれで俺んちができるって事
でしょう何だろうこの多分クリエイティブ
なのかなフォートナイトのクリエイティブ
モードでは自分のクリエイティブ自分で
自由にコンテンツを作成できますあマイ
クラ的なね自分の島では自分でルールを
設定して好きな人たちと好きなことして
遊べますおもろフォートナイトそんな言う
こともできるんだこれ皆さんも遊びます
このコード947466169937
打ち込めばみんなも遊べるって事でしょ
[音楽]
3億の豪邸観賞用ってありますはじめしゃ
ちょーの3億の豪邸
観賞用
サイドプレイヤー12芸術的建築物感動的
穏やか俺じゃんどうやって作ったのこれ
フォートナイトって今こんなことできるの
ちょっとプレイしてみましょうかもう
なんか書いてあるあこれTwitter
ですね作ってくださった方さあ家主がこの
ゲームをプレイするわけですからねどこ
まで再現できてるのか気になるのフォート
ナイトで俺んちが
フォートナイトで俺レンチあるけど
すごい
所沢まで作ってるしこの外の外壁と
[音楽]
ちょっと待って
どうも現実ですはいこれが実際の僕のお家
ですねあの再現度のやばいところこの木も
再現できてんじゃないですかここあとここ
ねこれもやばいよ海まで再現してるんだ
けど外の
すごいでマジでそこ海なんですよ
オレンジ着た製作者の方俺んち来たこれも
完璧です全く一緒だけどやばい
恐怖すら感じるレベルうわ外の宴席は全く
一緒ですしなんか通行止めになってますね
なんかオレンジで事件があったのかな
オールマイトプルスウルトラ
ちょっと待ってください
天才マジで一緒です俺本当にこれちょっと
待ってここまで完璧だと恐怖を感じるんだ
けども
えなんかここもこのここも車椅子も停め
てるとこなんですけどちょっとこの斜めに
なってるタイルとかも全く一緒なんですよ
途中から斜めになってるところも再現でき
てましたもうやばいパーフェクトです
フォートナイトでオレンジ失礼します表に
はもうここからいける
やばいやばい
俺のゾウがちゃんと置いたら俺似てねこれ
ちょっと似てるんだけど
どんだけ俺の動画をしっかり見てくれてる
んだ
ヤシの木3本もバッチリやってますえー
このカナンの感じもマジで一緒なんだけど
オレンジ入りました制作された方オレンジ
入りますねこれ螺旋階段も完璧こことかも
マジで全く違うんだけどやばいなぁ
いきなりごめんなさい前庭から見たんです
けど中から入っていこうと思います
失礼します
[音楽]
玄関全く一緒ここの窓ガラスもちゃんと
あるんですよこれどうも現実です
[音楽]
ここも一緒ですね1階のこの廊下の感じも
ね一緒ですよこれもう
プールルールスオレンジプールになって
ますねこれ
エレベーターですね
ここも一緒なの
やっぱごめん声出なくなっちゃったこれも
全く一緒ですねこのスライド式の倉庫も
ちゃんとありますねどうも現実です
なかなかこんな倉庫まで見せないよこの
画角かなちょっと狭くて分かりづらいかも
しれないんですけど
めっちゃ似てますね倉庫のこの感じ超
そっくりですちょっと待ってこれマジで
どうやって作ったの
一緒ですねはここも一緒です猫ちゃん
たくさん置いてある可愛いでここがえっと
俺がいつも撮影するえー
ピチューピチューが置いてありますねどう
も現実です
棚の位置ピチューの量前まではそこ鏡置い
てなかったので普通に外入れたのでもう
一生です
素晴らしいこれももう一生すごい
までしっかり置いてあるうわすごい
パソコンも置いてるしえ待って待って配置
全部
してるのか俺んちの
こっから前庭に出れるといや1階は完全に
オレンジですねこれすごいぞこれこれ
すごいですよ皆さんあのですねこれ
フォートナイトでこのコード入れたら皆
さんオレンジ遊びに来れます本当にでこの
階段登ってわここの踊り場も全く一緒2階
ですねここ
エレベーターを閉じて1番大きいお部屋
ですね
コーラも置いてあるコーラここはしてます
ね可愛い待ってマジですごいぞどうも現実
ですこの角度でしょうね多分この角度だと
思いますよ
完全に
完璧に合ってますコーラ再現するのが本当
センサーあるよねさっきの庭の螺旋階段に
続くのも全く一緒です
ヤバすぎ高校も全く一緒でこの鉄格子も
一緒ここからの景色もこれ一緒ですねとも
現実ですこれはここですねすごいよもう
完全一緒だもんこれもうで待って俺さ
わかんないんだけど普通さ動画見てたけど
俺んちは把握できるのこういう形とか空間
を和室も完璧ですねなんか書いてある
なんか猫ちゃんのフィギュアみたいになり
ますねはいここももうほぼ今同じ状態です
天井の奥行きとかもうわっ3回のこの障子
の感じも多分一緒だなこれどうも現実です
やべえよマジで
角度もこれも多分全く一緒なんだよね建築
デザイナーの方ですからね2階から裏には
いるんで行きましょうか
[音楽]
待ってくれよ待ってくれよこれやばいね
真ん中草生えてないでしょここ再現でき
てるのマジでやばいと思いますすごいやり
すぎだって
草の禿げ方も全く一緒なんですよ真ん中の
あたりで草が生えなくなっちゃっててこれ
を完全に一緒ですここも一緒うわやばいな
マジでこれあの家主が本当に家の持ち主が
いいんですけどまじで一緒ですよこれ車も
入ってる電通の場所も一緒です後ろの風景
も一緒ですこれ全く一緒ですあここは
ちょっと違いますねこの中が微妙に家具の
患者に似てるちょっとだけ形が
違ってるけどまだそんなに情報出してない
からかなここはちょっとだけあの現実とは
違いますけどもなんかイメージはすごい逆
にイメージでここまで作られてるのが本当
にやばいうわーこれオレンジでしかない
なぁやばいなまさかまさかフォートナイト
でオレンジの紹介する日が来るとは思わ
なかったよ3階行きます
うわあやべえはいここだけちょっと待って
待って
天才あなたは天才ですかこの部屋だけ暖色
なんですよライトが大正解です
[音楽]
洗面所の位置も完璧
何フォートナイトってさここまでリアルに
落ち作れるの
ベッド完璧に
あってヨギボーもちゃんと置いてあるはい
はいはいあーコンビニ部屋ですね今ここ
編集部屋になってるんですけどもちょっと
前まではこういう感じでコンビニの棚が
置いてありました
キッチンみたいな水出てる
下から
キッチンの感じと間取りも全部完璧ですね
うわーすげえちょっとあんまりあれ他の家
のことどうこう言えないですけども
ちょっとの景色もマジで似てる4回行き
ます
[音楽]
やばいやばいやばいやばいもうやばい
やばいやばいやばいやばいやばいやばい
全く一緒ここも一緒やばいうわあ俺今
まさにここにいるんですよここ俺今ここに
います4階のお風呂
ちょっと着実になってる
あーすごい世界一黒い部屋も再現されてる
すごい本当にちゃんと真っ暗で作ってくれ
たんだねえ
めっちゃ動画見てくれてありがとうござい
ますこれはね多分生半可なはじめしゃ
ちょー知識だと作れないですこれはかなり
動画を見てくれて部屋の間取りとかを
かなり計算してどこに何があるかも十分
理解してそしてかなり時間をかけて作られ
たんだと思いますちょっとどんぐらい
かかったら聞いてみよう作った方に聞いて
みたんですけども制作期間1ヶ月半かかっ
たみたいです
逆に1ヶ月半でここまで作れるんだなって
いうでなんかこれ今みたいにお散歩モード
もできるんですけどもこの
豪邸を作って鬼ごっこできるモードもある
らしいのでそれをちょっと1回だけやって
みたいと思いますあできましたはじめ
ハウスタグおもろすぎでしょフォート
ナイトというあんな超有名大人気ゲームで
オレンジで戦ってみようかね
やってみようと思います
[音楽]
みんなで遊べるって事これようこそ
オレンジ誰も嫌な人やってるって思って
ないだろうなあ
始まりますこの感じがするな隠れます
すごい楽しいオレンジでこれ鬼ごっこ知ら
ない人と
鬼ごっこでしょう誰よりも
この外
逃げるまま作戦です
あ誰かいたこんにちは
これ
あやばいやばい
んですけど
[音楽]
普通に面白いんだけど自分で言うのは何
ですけどねやっぱオレンジおもろいっすよ
[音楽]
重すぎでこれでこうやって見てみると俺ん
ちは鬼ごっこ用なのかあお二人ともいる
じゃんやばい
捕まっちゃう
うわなるほど鬼は超えてなんか
投げて何回か当てると多分
捕まっちゃうみたいな
やばいやばい
そこに意味ないんじゃない
よね
[音楽]
それはヤシの木の上は当てれるんだ
ヤシの木の上に当てれるんだね
あそこにいる
終わったんじゃないあーすごい鬼の勝ちだ
はいというわけでフォートナイトで初めて
社長のステージが登場しておりますこれ誰
でも行動打てば遊べるぽいのでぜひ皆さん
僕ん家に遊びに来てみてくださいすごいな
こんなの作れるんだ今フォートナイト
ちょっと感動したし1ヶ月半もこれに
費やしてくださったレオンさんというか
作っててくださったんですけども本当に
ありがとうございます感度恐怖が戦ってる
感じですぜひ皆さん遊んでみてください
鬼ごっこマジで面白かったですじゃあ
[音楽]
な